hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute einen weiteren teil der stick
serie heute geht es darum dass er schiff
zur insel traden das heißt ins
luftschiff in filters eindringen oder
musik ist tatsächlich ganz nice falls
sie den letzten teil von dieser stick
serie noch nicht gesehen und verlinkt
ich euch den irgendwo hier mal den könnt
ihr euch hier anschauen oder gar nicht
wir kriegen einfach mal auf play und
schauen was dieser teil uns diesmal so
zu bieten hat das sind wie immer wieder
ganz hübsch sind sie nicht bla bla mir
egal wir stimmen das ganze ok entweder
gehen wir über mit käppis die hell
cannonball oder treppe kann indem es
sich die hand das war die dümmste idee
aller zeiten
das ist bei diesem spiel nicht immer so
bohlen chain oder zero point energy in
nebenrollen chain
gut ich doch direkter
dieses pack spiel die spielen schon
diese ganzen credits ein und [ __ ] you
also wir gehen darüber mit der sticky
henn werden dass hin geschnitzt sind
dementsprechend direkt da drin und jetzt
entscheiden wir uns mal die zero point
energy
dabei das city-center täglichen nichts
geklappt hat einfach mal den ball bin
ich auch das okay laser cher oder frosta
wir nehmen einfach mal laser weil ist
ich bin laser laser sind cool und wenn
man eher tipp
dann versuchen wir es jetzt mal mit
gericht stuhl ich weiß zwar nicht was
bringt es geschafft okay der typ in
stein auf und das war der schneiden
viele müssen und jetzt ganz schnell
kommen ihm die spikes alles klar das hat
definitiv nicht funktioniert dann nehmen
wir dieses mal den boost kommt fällt
damit jack muss doch jetzt klappen oder
kommt okay okay okay laufen laufen
laufen schneller kleiner mann ist bohnen
einfach mal keine ahnung was dann
passieren da waren guten darm metal-fan
roque jump oder techno kommen wir nehmen
wir nehmen
rocket abkommen das jetzt ganz cool an
das steht auf dem boden und wir nehmen
einen jojo um gegen ihn zu kämpfen das
heißt was das ich erinnert mich gerade
ein bisschen an pokémon wir können
wieder bei psg fans oder götz nehmen wir
nehmen einfach mal die fans
scheiße
das ist einfach pokémon
todt mahnte kallas nicht yuan
henry gain 1000 experience standard ist
einfach tatsächliche pokemon sowie
müssten wir über wir probieren es mit
begrenzten schon mit boden geklappt hat
dann dass michael mit gail probieren jet
boost sich meinen damit war klar dass es
damit nicht klappt tatsache es hat
geklappt ok dummies missio tank oder
parachute wir versuchen mal tagen war
ich genau weiß dass ihr das alles hätte
falls wir haben gerade ein dokument
geschenkt bekommen ich weiß zwar nicht
bams geschafft wir haben
geschafft so kenne ich uns gar nicht
sonst brauchen wir dafür doch über 1000
versuche
wir können ja mal schauen was bei den
anderen sachen passiert wäre also wir
benutzen erst mal wieder hier schön den
kleider um auf die plattform zu kommen
und jetzt nehmen wir mal einfach mittel
heißt es mit ich weiß nicht wie das
ausgesprochen wird ja das war klar das
ist wenn wir rein theoretisch mal den
fallschirm nehmen können wir dann
einfach nicht da raus springen mit ihnen
genau jetzt irgendwie ein fallschirm
öffnen und die letzte sache die wir
hatten waren dummies das heißt wir
schmeißen die beiden runter der
helikopter verfolgt die bradley von mode
execute alter nice es gibt mehrere
möglichkeiten das ding zu gewinnen wenn
ihr die anderen möglichkeiten auch noch
austesten wollte googelt einfach nach
insel trading wert und würde ich sagen
wenn es euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen schreibt er
noch mal die kommentare ob eventuell
noch mehr von dieses big men gamespot
oder ob es da überhaupt noch welche gibt
und dann sehen wir uns ja